Once Upon a Time in Hollywood might turn out
to be a career landmark film from one of the
most exciting directors of this generation.
Here's everything you need to know before
you see Quentin Tarantino's newest movie.
It's been nearly four years since Tarantino's
last film, The Hateful Eight, and anticipation
has been building for his next flick ever
since.
Things really started to heat up in the summer
of 2017, when The Hollywood Reporter announced
that Tarantino's next project would be a film
set in Hollywood at the time of the Manson
murders.
The film secured distribution from Sony in
the fall of 2017, and by January of 2018 Leonardo
DiCaprio had signed on to work with Tarantino
again on the project.
The film spent the first six months of 2018
beefing up its cast as it headed into production.
When it came time for a release date, Sony
initially aimed for August 9th, 2019, which
would mark the 50th anniversary of Sharon
Tate's murder at the hands of the Manson Family.
By the summer of 2018, that release date had
changed to July 26th, with insiders noting
a release date in July would give the film
more time to play in front of summer audiences.
As of early July 2019, a large number of critics
and fans have yet to see the film, but we
do have its initial reaction from the Cannes
Film Festival to rely on in terms of its quality.
After its world premiere, Once Upon a Time
in Hollywood received a six-minute standing
ovation from the Cannes crowd, and reviews
coming out of the festival have been largely
positive.
Though the ending, which Peter Bradshaw from
The Guardian called "startling and provocative,"
proved divisive, most critics were pleased
with Tarantino's visual style, the replication
of 1960s Hollywood, and the chemistry between
first-time scene partners DiCaprio and Pitt.
So, while not everyone agrees, odds are this
is a movie worth looking forward to.
Like Inglourious Basterds and Django Unchained,
Once Upon a Time in Hollywood is set against
a very particular historical backdrop.
In both of those films, Tarantino took liberties
as he saw fit in an effort to best serve his
story, blowing up a whole plantation house
full of slavers in Django and flat-out machine-gunning
Hitler in the face in Basterds.
With the press billing the film as an "alternate
history," fans have developed a theory that
Tarantino will continue his tradition of toying
with our expectations about what really happened
in our own past.
The film is set in 1969 Hollywood, but Tarantino
didn't necessarily have to set his film in
our actual 1969 Hollywood.
This is, conceivably, a world in which Sharon
Tate could survive the night she was supposed
to be murdered, in which Manson could get
his comeuppance, and in which Hollywood could
move forward into some different version of
the future.
Like many Tarantino films, Once Upon a Time
in Hollywood quickly ignited a degree of controversy
after its premiere.
At a press conference to promote the film,
a New York Times journalist asked Tarantino
why Margot Robbie, nominated for an Oscar
for her work in I, Tonya, didn't get more
dialogue in the film as Sharon Tate.
The director was brief and dismissive with
his reply.
"Well, I just reject your hypotheses."
"Right."
Robbie then stepped in to offer her own answer
to the question, saying that she was able
to express numerous facets of Tate in a nonverbal
way.
"To really show those wonderful sides of her,
I think, could be adequately done without
speaking."
She added that it was "interesting" to be
able to explore the character even without
dialogue.
"Rarely do I get an opportunity to spend so
much time on my own as a character, going
through a day-to-day existence."
Over his nearly three decades of filmmaking,
Tarantino has developed a kind of stock company
of frequent collaborators, and many of them
returned to work with him again for Once Upon
a Time in Hollywood.
While Margot Robbie is a first-timer, both
DiCaprio and Pitt have worked with Tarantino
before, Pitt in Inglourious Basterds and DiCaprio
in Django Unchained.
The film will mark Kurt Russell's third time
working with Tarantino, Bruce Dern's second,
Michael Madsen's fourth, and stuntwoman and
actress Zoe Bell's sixth.
Sadly, one frequent Tarantino collaborator
apparently ended up on the cutting room floor:
Tim Roth, who's appeared in three Tarantino
features and the anthology film Four Rooms,
was cast in the film but did not appear in
the Once Upon a Time in Hollywood cut shown
at Cannes.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.